and we stripy jumpers do you own what do
you mean you're always wearing one well
first of all slimming and second Emily I
figure if it works with the tiger the B
and the humble tapir oky kind of make it
work for me here in the workplace that's
an evolutionary benefit for animals
living in the wild the scramble for free
office fruit not an evolutionary
struggle but people always take the
bananas first it's really unfair anyway
fine the games involved what wait is
this because it involves coming out and
you've heard the word evolved a lot and
now all you can think about is evolved
know what's an evolved it's not unusual
for games to change course a little
during development gameplay gets tweaked
stories get refined but every few
millennia evolution leaps forward isn't
that from x-men take halo before
Microsoft bought bungee combat Evolved
started life as a sci-fi version of
bungee series myth it was an RTS title
that was due to release simultaneously
on both pc and mac and nothing comes out
on mac halo then briefly flirted with
third-person action before swapping to
the first person view point that we all
know and love you were softer no
strangers to franchise evolution like
the drift a retro sci-fi third-person
shooter set in a city floating in the
clouds its team was ambitious but
inexperienced development flailed and
NuBus off tried to save the game by
pitching it as a James Bond title when I
didn't take the drift were shelved but a
couple of years later reawakened with
the now familiar name of splinter cell
Assassin's Creed came from the can't
sands of time spinoff prince of persia
assassins the idea came from sands of
time director Patrice désilets interest
in the real-life assassin order the
spin-off would have you playing as a
female body guard escorting a young
prince in Jerusalem Ubisoft didn't like
this for a prince of persia game because
you weren't playing as the prince so the
entire team shifted their focus to this
new IP which turned out to be a good
decision because assassins became wildly
successful /e and stylish hack and slash
Devil May Cry started life as an early
version of Resident Evil 4 rezzy creator
shinji mikami
he passed the torch for the frightening
franchise to Resident Evil 2 director
Hideki Kamiya the story revolved around
an invincible cool guy named Tony who's
great intellect and super skills were
explained away by biotechnology kamiya
felt that Tony was just too damn cool
and stylish to be held back by rezzies
fixed camera angles and so introduce the
dynamic camera mikami felt that this new
resident evil deviated too far from its
claustrophobic origins and encourage the
team to make it a new game over time
Tony became Dante and it turned into the
DMC that we know today I feel like we've
learned a lot today games just don't pop
out readymade they have to take their
sweet time and more from the primordial
ooze of games but what if they don't
evolve over time so what if there's just
one creator like gaben all glory to Lord
gaben okay
save your manager day god help us all
and the humble gazelle tapir stop it
nope did you see the lands these streets
are made of cheese then we can we go
away don't we go okay